I was 13 when I first got access to a computer.
My parents bought me a Macintosh in 1984 when I was eight years old.
I was in the sixth grade.
I learned to code in college.
Freshman year first semester, Intro to Computer Science.
I wrote a program that played tic-tac-toe.
I think it was pretty humble beginnings.
I think the first program I wrote asked things like, "What's your favorite color?"...
...or, "How old are you?"
I first learned how to make a green circle and a red square appear on the screen.
The first time I actually had something come up and say, "Hello world"...
...and I made a computer do that; it was just astonishing.
Learning how to program didn't start off as...
...wanting to learn all of computer science...
...or trying to master this discipline or anything like that.
It just started off because I wanted to do this one simple thing.
I wanted to make something that was fun for myself and and my sisters.
I wrote this little program, and then basically just added a little bit to it.
And then when I needed to learn something new...
...I looked it up either in a book or on the Internet...
...and then added a little bit to it.
It's really not unlike playing an instrument or something...
...or you know, playing a sport.
It starts out being very intimidating,...
...but you kind of get the hang of it over time.
Coding is something that can be learned...
...and I know it can be intimidating, a lot of things are intimidating,...
...but you know, what isn't?
A lot of the coding that people do is actually fairly simple.
It's more about the process of breaking down problems...
...than coming up with complicated algorithms...
...as people traditionally think about it.